bonjour monsieur le président j'ai
écouté comme tous les adhérents de vers
et d'hommes république et développement
outre mer avec grand intérêt votre
allocution du 9 novembre dernier
vous avez parlé particulièrement du
chômage et donc de la nécessité de faire
revenir à l'emploi ceux de nos
concitoyens qui ont sont éloignés
trois cent mille de nos concitoyens sont
concernés en territoires d'outre-mer
monsieur le président vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir quand territoires
d'outre-mer la cherté de la vie et
reconnu au moins à 30 % supérieure à
celle que nous avons aujourd'hui en
france hexagonale
cela veut dire monsieur le président que
lorsqu'on donne le même salaire un
ultramarin ou à quelqu'un de la france
hexagonale dans la réalité on donne un
salaire un ultramarin de 30% inférieur à
celui qui est perçu en france hexagonale
et 30% inférieurs monsieur le président
cela veut dire que nous rémunérons
aujourd'hui le smic à 880 euros c'est
l'équivalent monsieur le président
alors
touché un salaire de 200 euros inférieur
au seuil de pauvreté en france
ça n'est pas comme cela qu'on va arriver
d'une part à motiver les gens qui sont
éloignés de l'emploi et d'autre part
probablement aussi à motiver ceux qui
sont contraints au travail dans de
telles conditions
l'équité monsieur le président commandes
que chacun de nos concitoyens soit à la
même enseigne un dispositif a été
inventé il ya déjà de très nombreuses
années pour permettre aux fonctionnaires
de récupérer cet écart de salaire de
sorte à faire face à la cherté de la vie
ce dispositif coûte environ un milliard
et demi d'euros eh bien nous chez les
dogues monsieur le président nous vous
demandons d'une part par souci d'équité
mais d'autre part parce que c'est un
investissement que la nation fait dans
le travail c'est un investissement que
la nation fait dans l'économie des
territoires de trois maires de faire en
sorte qu'aucun salaire soit inférieur à
1650 euros c'est à dire les 1260 euros
de smic plus de 30% sur têt kalé
monsieur le président cette équité est
nécessaire elle ne peut pas être mise à
la charge aujourd'hui des entreprises
des entreprises sont ce qu'elles peuvent
dans les territoires d'outre-mer pour
payer au mieux leurs salariés récupérer
cet écart leur est impossible c'est donc
un effort de la nation qui doit être
fait et ça n'est pas un effort social
monsieur le président c'est un effort
sociétale c'est un effort d'équité c'est
un effort qui permet à chacun de se
sentir en égalité c'est à dire monsieur
le président de se sentir inclus dans la
nation monsieur le président les
adhérents des raiders sont derrière vous
pour pousser cette nécessité pour faire
en sorte qu' il n'y ait plus d'écarts
qu'il n'ya plus d'inégalités entre eux
les citoyens d'outre-mer et les citoyens
de la france hexagonale je vous remercie